noch lernen und schreien sie die schüler
des elsa brändström gymnasiums im
nordrhein-westfälischen oberhausen
doch gleich werden sie betroffenen
schweigen elias trittin der
zehntklässler will seine mitschüler
schockieren er zeigt ihnen das abschieds
video von am ende tot die 15 jährige
kanadierin schreibt darin meine angst
wurde es schlimmer ich konnte nicht mehr
rausgehen
kurz danach bringt sie sich um
jahrelang wurde sie im internet gemobbt
weil ein fremder ein oben ohne foto von
ihr ins netz gestellt hatte ihr
abschieds video auf facebook eine
warnung an alle cyber mobbing kann
tödlich sein
elias ist einer von mittlerweile 360
medienscouts in nordrhein westfalen seit
knapp zwei jahren setzt man hier auch
schüler als medienexperten
hier erhebt kein lehrer mahnend den
zeigefinger
hier wird auf augenhöhe aufgeklärt und
das wirkt
so schockierend
fand schon immer schon ein bisschen
gedanken überhaupt passieren kann hätte
jetzt nicht gedacht wirklich nicht ich
finde es klasse da marco viele chia hat
das projekt ins leben gerufen
er ist informatik lehrer am elsa
brändström gymnasium
er weiß dass ein großteil des lebens
seiner schüler über das internet
stattfindet und dass viele sich keine
gedanken darüber machen was das für
folgen haben kann
weder für sich noch für andere mobbing
das hätte es an schulen schon immer
gegeben so der lehrer aber cybermobbing
das hätte eine ganz andere qualität es
sei schlimmer und härter
cyber mobbing kann rund um die uhr
passieren beispielsweise also während
man früher auf dem schulhof oder auch
die nachhauseweg oder so etwas sogar
eine attacke hatte können die jetzt
einfach 24 stunden am tag stattfinden
ich habe sofort ein relativ großes
publikum das heißt das sehen sofort viel
viel mehr menschen als bei einem
klassischen morgen ein effekt den ich
persönlich ganz schlimm finde ist das
publikum ist unbekannt ich weiß einfach
nicht wer solch eine attacke mitbekommen
hat ein foto ist von mir im netz ein
video ich weiß nicht wer das gesehen hat
das sind natürlich einfach dinge die die
qualität des mobbings dann verschlimmern
cybermobbing ist weltweit ein problem im
niederländischen arnheim ändert eine
facebook fehde mit einem mord angeblich
hat die 15 jahre alte will sie bei
facebook behauptet ihre freundin paula
besetzt mit mehreren jungen die sehr
recht sich soll ihren 14 jährigen freund
damit beauftragt haben
winsi zu erstechen
in den usa film der student darum rawi
seinen schwulen mit studenten tyler
heimlich beim sex und stellt das video
im internet seine cyberattacke treibt
das opfer in den selbstmord und fiese
lügen im netz setzen dem erst 13
jährigen joel aus österreich so zu dass
er sich vor einen zug wirft ein freund
hatte ein bild von trail mit photoshop
auf eine pornographische seite gesetzt
und jede medial vermittelt für
kommunikation ist eben ist eben keine
face to face kommunikation das heißt ich
sehe nicht wie der andere reagiert
und dann ist es natürlich mal schnell
eine bereinigung geschrieben schneller
irgendetwas gemacht weil ich das leid
eines opfers ja praktisch nicht sehen
kann
das ist das was man als online
enthemmung effekt bezeichnet also sprich
ich sehe das nicht und reagieren
vielleicht deshalb stärker sollte es an
der schule von lehrer viele chia trotz
aufklärung zu einer cyber attacke kommen
dann gibt es noch medienscouts wie elias
trittin
an ihn können sich die schüler
vertrauensvoll wenden die sache dass man
sich auch leuten öffnen muss und es ist
nur was anderes wenn man seinem
erwachsenen geht und sagt ja ich werde
das halber gemobbt die sagen dass sie
sagen dass vielleicht etwas peinliches
was man eltern nicht sagen würde
dafür sind wir eben medienstar am elsa
brändström gymnasium in oberhausen so
medien scout elias sei in letzter zeit
nichts mehr passiert das liege
sicherlich auch an veranstaltungen wie
heute die schüler verlassen gestärkt die
aula sie wissen jetzt was ein kommentar
anrichten kann
und sie wissen auch wir ihnen im
ernstfall erste hilfe leisten wird